how is five and love in the closet is
weird
one night you're out with your friends
you have a few too many drinks then you
run into how unfair do you have a scene
in a while and you're walking home
together before you know it it just like
happens and boom you kissed him and it's
weird because it's like the first kiss
you have that feels real
the first kiss that you don't have to
think like Oh am I doing this right it
just feels so right and that's the first
time it's ever felt right but then comes
the worst part should I not have done
that is he gonna tell everyone is he gay
am i gay yes okay okay then you start
overthinking things and you're just like
wait a second that did you mean to kiss
me today did I do it by accident you
wake up thinking about it you go to bed
thinking about it and then you don't
talk about it for days and those days
feel like months because you've never
been this happy but also nervous and
scared and sad all at the same time
something that you've been wishing for
for so long just happened and it feels
like as good as this is this might
actually be really bad for you but then
one of you finally brings it up and
you're like oh thank god
and then you're just like should I
apologize I'm sorry for kissing you it
turns out that you're both gay and just
saying I'm gay out loud for the first
time feels incredible so you start
seeing each other more and more and you
hang out more and you kiss more you
laugh more and time flies and you're
still afraid but you're freaked together
and somehow
feels better this morning the Supreme
Court recognized that the Constitution
guarantees marriage equality same-sex
marriage legal in this country across
every and suddenly you are observed
bigger than your downs and the news are
thinking I want to be with this person
all the time love love is a little
complicated when you're in the closet
love is hard to explain when it's a
secret love is hard to explain when you
can't show it love is hard to explain
when you're not allowed to explain it
but you try anyways and sometimes that
explanation doesn't go great right away
[Music]
it's hard
[Music]
so your love has to be slow and cautious
and your love has to be just a friend
your love has to be just a co-worker
your love has to be non-existent but
then you see other people's love and
their love is open their love is free
their love is quick like two months in
they're engaged quick the situation
sucks because you're happy for them but
deep down you're a little jealous cuz
why can't you love someone so openly why
can't your love just walk into the house
and be accepted why can't your love like
a your love matter voice of your
redemption
[Music]
coming through
[Music]
the Mayans
[Music]
you want to introduce this person that
you love to people and your friends and
you want to post pictures to you you
want to show the world that you love
this person it just doesn't feel like an
option because it's hard to explain when
people think it's wrong so you don't do
you do
[Music]
[Music]
you crystal back
[Music]
give it time
[Music]